I come to this video playing net trust
net roster you don't know okay let's um
let's play the French okay and I'll try
with them we know the sideline I
sometimes play with 97 okay he's taking
on d5 bit of a spoil sport line check
not not bad for white at all can be
recommended what I'm trying to do is get
rid of the light squared Bishop and he
allowed that trade so I'm glad that I
managed to to do that on the other hand
he will probably take with the sea pawn
and this means that he has improved his
pawn structure slightly okay one problem
could be that i'm a bit weak on the dark
squares meaning that most like night h5
and Bishop age 6 are are sometimes a
problem need to be need to be am aware
of that let's say good night h5 and
Bishop age six if you could play two
moves in a row i'm in trouble attacking
g7 i cannot move the jeep on due to
Knight f6 okay
that's a bit of a strange one because
though his rookie has not defended can i
play night to g6 rookie a true key 8 age
5 yeah thus we have come to a groupie
one checker which looks um looks
tempting but I wait I have an idea maybe
this is completely completely bogus but
it's interesting okay let's check this
rookie ATM he will play I'll recapture
age 5 i'm giving this check nope okay I
thought h5 look you want checking edge
295 the interesting technical idea okay
well this I'm not sure about f6 oh-6 is
going to play h5
okay I'd like to get rid of this PCM is
playing age five hundreds clear yeah i'm
yeah this was probably a bad idea really
allowing him to to to play Knight to f5
and thus I cannot really prevent now and
yeah that was bad okay I'd like to
prevent night at five this is such a
such an ugly move to phase let's see
it's not what i rly dreamt about getting
the night bear well it's not great on c6
so maybe it's not not not a big issue
hmm I don't know about that this is a
good idea really
well d 4 is slightly weak now if he goes
Queen g4 f9 txt 52 sir typically no
trick our d4s hanging but you're
probably playing 23 so better moves that
we should be five i have f six so
probably needs to retreat
yeah might take c5 if it takes D 797
rugby 7 this is not nice yeah I'm still
pretty optimistic here maybe this is
completely uncalled for the car system
has quite a number of weaknesses night
this night is coming to f6 and now i
have b5 this is an important point if it
takes up a song i take the bishop so he
put this on d6 but this is also a
liability slightly behind all the clock
always always a problem
yeah Queen to Queen 2f form
hmm i don't really see how to improve
here I could have taken age five how
stupid is dead I could have just taken
age 5 and this is actually really
important stupid really stupid
okay that's not the end of the world but
the time situation is getting more and
more serious
30 seconds that's the main problem I
mean really not sure about the position
but it's hanging on d4 and III is
hanging okay but 20 seconds I need to
play fast moves
h5 hang time morning and take it check
tween edge 3m stronger check check check
check check seven seconds check check
check no Queen III check check check
check check good on Alderaan yeah of
course it's a it's completely winning
but one second one second left yeah okay
well probably should have made it
somehow winning I mean mating him or or
whatever but it was really tough with
with no time between age to wear
whatever it's minus nine or something
yeah it was a very tense game the main
what really annoys me is that I could
have just taken here and this basically
ends it without the pawnees got
absolutely no play on the Kings side
this bind this is lifted and I can at
the appropriate moment play g6 and get
get rid of the night not immediately it
takes a while but getting rid of the
pawn is huge this was very very simple
and here it's um it's just complicated
and hard too hard to tell what's going
on we need 30 seconds
so tricky to play and he blundered all
kinds of stuff rookie 3 as much easier
now but I only saw it after I played a
six and here he I didn't want to do that
because of the beep on it's probably
good anyway but I wanted to play a more
clearer structure and this is keeps
keeps keeps an edge of course ok 19
seconds this is the main the main
problem yeah okay i hope you liked it
was very tense at the end thanks for
watching